[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing what happened
to the morally ambivalent malfoy family
draco
lucius and narcissa it's no question
that in the end
in his heart draco wasn't a villain but
his parents
particularly his father definitely had a
lot of demons
they followed lord voldemort until near
the bitter end
which begs the question were they
pardoned for their crimes
the malfoys are one of the most arrogant
families from the entire series
they are actively and extremely
prejudiced toward muggles
and muggleborns stemming from some sort
of weird
bloodline superiority complex throughout
the series
they are a nuisance to harry in the trio
particularly draco
and what started off as harmless
bullying transformed into something more
sinister
as time went on the malfoys were the
followers of the dark lord himself
though obviously after his defeat at the
end of the first wizarding war
lucius weaseled his way out of
punishment by declaring that he only
followed the dark lord
because he was under the imperious curse
his freedom was obviously not deserved
as he was a fully-fledged death eater
however his true colours were finally
revealed when he was imprisoned after
the events of the order of the phoenix
particularly for his role in the battle
of the department of mysteries when the
books and films first start
the malfoys don't appear to be much of a
threat but as voldemort slowly regains
power
they too become a greater threat by the
time the deathly hallows rolls around
voldemort is certainly back in some kind
of a position of power
his greatest threat donald always dead
he has amassed a legion of followers
once more
and he has taken hogwarts provided that
the malfoys were followers of lord
voldemort
one would presume they were comfortable
at this point but it was actually quite
the opposite
extremely upset and disappointed with
lucius's performance in the order of the
phoenix
voldemort made a point of punishing the
malfoy family from the half-blood prince
onward
draco was used and abused by voldemort
later to be assigned the nearly suicidal
mission
of killing dumbledore himself something
which voldemort knew
draco would never be able to accomplish
voldemort had waged psychological
warfare on the malfoy's
and knowing that he held total power
over them he fully took advantage of his
situation
he wielded his power to the point they
no longer wanted to follow him
but they were in too deep which meant
that when voldemort was finally defeated
they were in a particularly strange
position they were probably happy that
he was defeated
but at the same time they knew that in
the eyes of the wizarding world
they were death eaters they were
voldemort's loyal followers
with voldemort gone they no longer had
the security blanket that came with any
kind of association to him
and this meant that their fate was
entirely up to the good guys
the rest of the wizarding world when it
started to look
like voldemort may be defeated the
malfoy family
simply hung their heads and walked away
from the hogwarts grounds
in shame so what came of them were they
given life imprisonment in azkaban
or were they forced to endure some other
equally awful fate
it would appear that after the events of
the deathly hallows
lucius and his family managed to avoid
sentencing by revealing information
names etc about the surviving death
eaters
ensuring that the wizarding world could
move forward in perfect harmony
with no more spikes in evil meant that
capturing the remaining death eaters
was of utmost importance therefore when
lucius willfully offered to reveal this
information
in exchange for him and his family's
freedom the ministry of magic
which was in tatters at that point was
more than willing to take him up on it
during the epilogue scene of the films
we also clearly see
a much more mature looking draco malfoy
with a family of his own
sending off his own son to hogwarts
suggesting that draco malfoy
was entirely pardoned for his role and
actions in the second wizarding war
so they were pardoned for their crimes
great but what was next for the malfoy's
let's take a look at draco first draco
started at hogwarts
in the same year as harry ron hermione
and many of the other characters that
we're also familiar with
right from the beginning draco exhibits
questionable behavior
he's the archetypal bully and when he
first meets harry in the film
he extends his hand out to him but not
before taking an easy shot
at ronald weasley who harry had also
just met make my name's funny do you
no need to ask you yours red hair and a
hand-me-down robe
you must be a weasley right off the bat
we sort of get a sense of the type of
character
that draco malfoy is going to be the
only reason that he's interested in
befriending harry
is because of his fame and draco having
been raised in a pureblood family that
places an exceptional amount of value on
status
leaps at the opportunity to associate
himself with harry
throughout the books and films draco is
a constant nuisance towards the trio
and as he grows older his behavior turns
from annoying but still
childlike and playful to rather sinister
we are able to witness first hand
his evolution from petulant but innocent
little boy
to dark troubled young man and what
largely set him off was the imprisonment
of his father
we see draco become more and more
involved with the death eaters as the
films progress
but despite talking the talk it appeared
that draco was almost always hesitant
in performing the duties of the death
eaters when push came to shove
you see draco never wanted to be a death
eater he just wanted to make his parents
proud
he just wanted to live up to the family
name even if it wasn't truly him
by the time the deathly hallows rolled
around it became rather evident that
draco was remorseful for his actions
and that much of his behavior was
derived from increasing pressure from
his father
when voldemort had finally been defeated
and his family was granted freedom
draco's character matured considerably
and he ended up becoming a much better
man than his father
in an interview rowling expressed that
draco was
sobered by his experiences as a death
eater and went on to describe his life
post deathly hallows on pottermore the
biggest revelation was that he became
less of a pureblood fanatic
the events of draco's late teens forever
changed his life
he had had the beliefs with which he had
grown up challenged in the most
frightening way
he had experienced terror and despair
seen his parents suffer for their
allegiance
and had witnessed the crumbling of all
that his family had believed in
people whom draco had been raised or
else had learned to hate
such as dumbledore had offered him help
and kindness and harry potter had given
him his life after the events of the
second wizarding war
lucius found his son as affectionate as
ever but refusing to follow the same old
pure bloodline
draco married the younger sister of a
fellow slytherin a story of green grass
who had gone through a similar
though less violent and frightening
conversion from pure blood ideals to a
more tolerant life view
was felt by narcissa and lucius to be
something of a disappointment as a
daughter-in-law
they had high hopes of a girl whose
family featured on the sacred 28
but as astoria refused to raise their
grandson scorpius
in the belief that muggles were scum
family gatherings were often fraught
with tension
also he seemingly mellowed out a bit
leading a life of leisure
instead of working to overturn the
forces of light or establish dominion
over muggles
like lucius did i imagine that draco
grew up to lead a modified version of
his father's existence
independently wealthy without any need
to work draco inhabits malfoy manor with
his wife and son
i see in his hobbies further
confirmation of his dual nature
the collection of dark artifacts harks
back to family history
even though he keeps them in glass cases
and does not use them
however his strange interest in
alchemical manuscripts
from which he never attempts to make a
philosopher's stone hints had to wish
for something other than wealth
perhaps even the wish to be a better man
i have high hopes that he will raise
scorpius to be a much kinder
and more tolerant malfoy than he was in
his own youth
draco's character was certainly always
one of dubious morality
and whether you like it or not through
the passage of time draco did become a
good
sound man in rowling's own words there
is
after all some unextinguished good at
the heart of draco
as fellucius and narcissa it seems like
they kept a relatively low profile after
being pardoned
however we can derive from the text on
pottermore particularly the segment on
family gatherings being fraught with
tension
that they were a little too set in their
ways to change their whole philosophy
they weren't openly evil anymore and i
highly doubt that they could ever be
convinced to join a pure blood cause
again
but they certainly still held the same
beliefs that they always held
and weren't any more tolerant of muggles
or half bloods
and that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it did you guys already know
what happened to the malfoys
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
if we are the ones to hand potter to the
dark lord everything will be as it was
you understand
[Music]
you